1 voici un engin à quoi il rit pourquoi
à quoi sert cet homme c'est le cameraman
qui la voient derrière quel fou rire
l'image bouge
à quoi sert cet objet trois versions et
c'est jean marie qui va nous donner la
première ça va tellement de quoi rire
marque c'était l'objet amusant c'est une
petite invention c'est un arroseur un
arroseur pour petit jardin petit et
moyen jardin en effet il suffit que
l'eau monte paris si oui par le trophée
est ici c'est sur une source d'eau l'eau
monte arrive dans cette chose hélicoïdal
et ça se met à tourner suivant la force
de pression alors vous arrosez plus ou
moins loin suivant la force avec le
robinet vous tournez savane pierre
perret ça nous allons gérer vassilian
propriété énorme évidemment y apprend on
apprend que c'est pour des gens qui ont
un petit jardin pas de corps et l'emmène
voir ici celui-ci spectre est prévu il
ya une petite poire ici et on l'a rouge
chez soi le au barça 3 qui va laisser à
ses gamins la version pierre perret de
la rose heure de gloire
on introduit sa délicatement
on introduit délicatement cet objet dans
dans une roue de fromage mais laissez
moi finir dans une roue de fromage mais
auparavant il faut bien s'assurer que la
pâte soit molle évidemment j'ai lui même
et vous ne pourrez pas pénétrer et mou
comme il est voyez-vous est en fait
rentrer dans la pâte molle le plus loin
possible
effectivement et et en retire doucement
ce qui fait une cheminée d'aération
voyez vous on le retire qui s'écroule de
riz et ça sert exactement à affiner le
comté parce que dans cette bouche
d'aération par le truchement de cette
bouche d'aération le fromage peut
commencer à s'affiner voilà et on sort
une espèce de petit bouchon c'est une
cheminée et voici la version 2 de ja au
monsieur je ne ferai pas de commentaire
monsieur cet objet vous rappelle par le
bout la queue en tire-bouchon du cochon
et bien effet cet appareil sert pour
l'insémination artificielle détruits je
n'ajouterai rien sinon que ne fait pas
autrui ce que vous ne voudriez pas alors
trois versions s 1 pour l'arroseur
arrosé
l'arroseur de gloire incessants heure de
gloire
1 comme le disait jean marie est ce pour
faire des trous dans le fromage pour
l'aérer ou alors un inséminateur
artificielle l'inséminateur artificielle
penser que c'est jackie a dit la vérité
lassus cochon qui s'en dédit fier en
effet c'est monsieur jean lebeau qui
nous envoyait c'est un appareil son
commentaire pour lacer médiation a dit
michel des cochons voilà c'est bien